Looks like they're here.
You said you are going to hand over
the AHRV agent as well.
We've brought the String Puppets
as promised.
The returnees
are being transported here now as well.
And the AHRV agent?
She should be arriving shortly!
You don't have everything as promised.
Please wait!
They'll definitely bring her.
You'll send back the people
on the list as promised, right?
-I'm going back, right?
-Just as I thought.
We will check the AHRV weapons first.
This is so high!
I knew this would happen.
Lu and I will take care
of the enemies here.
Marimari, go protect the buses!
Got it!
You have chosen to resist us!
No, we didn't!
What's going on? Hurry and make them stop!
Muta!
For the charge of assisting the enemy,
you're under arrest!
Stay away from me!
Something has appeared!
Keisaku! Where are you?
What's going on?
Thanks!
Marimari!
Good job!
Daisuke!
You can leave the rest to me!
Help!
No!
-Why, you!
-Wait, Lu!
We can't let them split up our firepower.
Let's return to Marimari!
We need to make adjustments
to collect the materials.
They have no love for mankind.
They're just a bunch of egoists.